hi I'm Lego lead designer Jonathan  Bening 2020 marks the 35th anniversary  of the original Nintendo Entertainment  System and we're feeling a little  nostalgic which is why we are excited to  unveil the new Lego NES this incredible  brick-built set includes the iconic NES  control deck and a retro style TV that  revolutionizes classic 8-bit graphics  everything will instantly feel familiar  to any as fans from plugging in your  controller to loading your favorite game  cartridge  and when you're done building jump into  the action on the level of the original  Super Mario Brothers  speaking of Mario this guy always has to  trick up its sleeve and Lego Mario from  the Lego Super Mario starter course is  no different just put him on top of the  TV and start pranking to truly bring the  Lego NES to life now you're playing with  color and bricks we hope you enjoyed the  new Lego Nintendo Entertainment System  as much as the original and yes  you